ted extravaganza the vegas spectacular
is the true definition of an
extravaganza you can see the show over
at bally's filled with dancers skaters
acrobatics showgirls and so much more
here to tell us all about the show we
have a few performers madison and oscar
thank you guys for being here thank you
for having us so i have seen the show
before it truly is the definition of
extravaganza but for those who haven't
seen the show let's talk a little bit
about it and what people can expect when
they come to see it
extravaganza there's just this massive
variety um we basically follow a young
man uh he's a bit down on his luck and
he somehow finds himself in the
beautiful city of las vegas
and it's just basically a journey of
self-discovery of everything that
las vegas has to offer just
you know love
self-discovery everything we have
acrobats salsa dancers tap dancers uh
amazing thrill-seeking motorbike riders
from the globe of death um yeah so i was
going to say oscar you're dressed for
the part tell us about your role in the
show it's a dangerous one very dangerous
very very dangerous um we do the
motorcycle riding in a sphere haven't
seen them before oh yeah it's scary in
those cages yeah and um we are the only
one showing vegas performing that
act right now yes wow okay i gotta ask
you how do you get into that and that
first time that you really go in and
you're going upside down like what's
going through your mind
well i come i come back from my
background the uh
riders all my family they are motorcycle
riders like my my grandfather my uncles
and my cousins so i was just part of it
it's just like natural for me threw you
into it yeah i thought i know anytime i
see that act and you see that up close
it is the most nerve-wracking thing but
it really adds something special to the
show and in addition to that i mean
dancers can meet a little bit of
everything and it is family friendly too
right it is um it definitely has
something for everybody it has you know
comedians dances
just a variety and it is so family
friendly it's it's just a beautiful
story it's something that
when you look out into the audience and
you do see young children and families
it it gives us happiness and hope as
well so
yeah bring everybody along it is truly
an event to come see yeah and so many
acts packed into one and you guys are
doing a fun summer special can you tell
us about that so if anyone out there
wants to come see you guys i think it's
starting now yes so summer is always a
great time in las vegas um and there's
one of the biggest productions on the
show on the strip sorry we would love to
be one of the most affordable so we have
ticket prices starting as low as 35
which is amazing for the
absolute talent from all over the globe
that is put onto that stage so
grab your friends grab your family come
see us have a great night
um yeah i hope you love us 35 you can't
beat that and i can vouch for it it's
non-stop entertainment from beginning to
end so thank you guys for coming here
everyone go see the show it's perfect
for the summer especially when it's
getting hot go inside stay cool and have
some fun so thank you guys for being
here be sure to go see extravaganza the
vegas spectacular it performs nightly it
is dark on thursdays it's at the jubilee
theater inside valleys and yep they have
that special all-new offer for 35 a
ticket that's to celebrate summer and
you can get those at valleyslasvegas.com
jc